321 co und allem den angriffen war
verboten weiß schon deswegen will ich
sagen egal mit was schon herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge und wir
spielen heute eine weiteres mal
minecraft team jump league und ich komme
gar nicht klar wie man hier sehr gut
erkennen kann
leute ich hab mir heute was zugelegt was
man leben massiv verbessern wird massiv
an marcel volkes an
ja massiv wird ein vorbeikommen mein
leben verbessern weil ich mir das
zugelegt habe weil das einkommen so ein
ghetto kraft kümmert sich dann um meine
finanziellen sorgen sagte jäger die
rechnung bezahlt ich für dich dann wenn
es wenn ich mal keine zeit zu trainieren
geht er für mich trainieren und so das
halt ganz geil dankeschön massiv zweites
oder gar massiv smartcard glaube ich der
bergbahn erlassen
aber für alle anderen habe ich mir heute
einen ventilator gekauft leute ich bin
heute morgen in den supermarkt auf
baumarkt genannt in den baum ab wenn ich
gegangen und habe mir da einiges
zugelegt unter anderem mücken gitter
damit ich nachts im märz airbus werde
von den mücken es bei uns echt echt
schlimm wenn richtige mückenplagen hier
return of the match ich wechsele es
einfach schon mal hier verzeiht mir dass
mücken sind bei uns echt dramatisch
und deswegen muss ich mir muss ich mir
aber so ein ding zu legen weil ich sonst
richtig leiden stream ich hier abends
irgendwie drei stunden langen ist die
luft so richtig stecke ich in meinem
zimmer weil es auch nicht so groß ist
und dann kann ich aber nach sich das
fenster aufmachen beim schlafen weil
sonst mücken reinkommen würde nämlich
komplett auseinander nehmen würden
wie man im volksmund sagt und deswegen
müssen wir dazu gelegt aber jagd und ich
genau unten ventilator leute ventilators
auch gerade an
habt ihr es davor schon gehört bevor ich
das gesagt habe oder nicht wie es mit
dem ventilator
ich habe meinen kleinen test durchlaufen
lassen und da schien es mir als wir
alles in ordnung und ich würde den klang
nicht zu versteuern weil das mikrofon
mittlerweile sehr sehr nah
an meinem einer birne das heißt
störgeräusche alter kommen weniger durch
gerade was ist heute bei dir passiert
die geht's deiner verdauung mehr einer
versorgung mit super heute ist gar nicht
so viel passiert war ziemlich lange wach
aber dann ist meine nichte gekommen
damit ich mit ihr bisschen spazieren
gegangen
wir sahen zusammen auf toilette
unser geschäft wird am samstag ein jahr
alt multicar schön laufen und so richtig
cool ist die so richtig advanced oder
japan hatte eigentlich es voll hätte ich
mal drüber nachdenken war auch so ein
kleiner scheißer sind allerdings ja aber
ich bin auch lange wach geblieben
tatsächlich und zwar war ich gestern
einfach ich hab mein mitbewohner fifa
gespielt mal wieder nach langer langer
zeit weil wir gestern bei der hausarbeit
abgegeben haben wir gedacht können wir
uns mal darauf eine runde fifa und wir
fingen dann irgendwann an
dann würde so ein paar runden gespielt
und alles um mega konzentriert natürlich
erkennt dass vielleicht auch wenn ihr
selbst wie vor spielt man das richtig
ärgert sich und dann schauen was auf die
uhr auf einmal war es einfach drei uhr
nachts die ps3 gespielt
das ist nicht das ist nicht normal
playmate ihr sagt immer dass hier enorme
aber das ist nicht normal das ist auch
bist du auch gab bei diesem komischen
richtig hässlichkeit die das ist nicht
normal aber ich habe ja noch übrigen
bisschen glück schrägstrich es gab
deswegen kann ich ja ganz gut durch aber
planet ist echte bisschen gemein
geworden letzter zeit habe ich gefühl
die verkauften einem recht deutlich
deutlich schwerere leider wie hessen als
norma ich das gefühl dass die deutlich
schwerer geworden sind die sache
ich weiß nicht wie er empfindet ihr dass
falls ihr selbst auch jump league spielt
seit so gut dass meine kommentare 1
ich persönlich finde echt ist es
schwieriger geworden die optik ist
wirklich schwieriger geworden in letzten
zeiten wie manier
wie macht ihr das habt ihr dazu meinung
oder wollt ihr entscheidung wo denn
entscheiden karte.de katyn euro schein
haben dann schreibt uns in die
kommentare
ansonsten ist natürlich alles nach wie
vor super wenn ich irgendwann sich quer
durch alle verbrennen
die nummer lautet ihnen das hier
programmiert habe ich werde es euch an
ihr kriegt irgendwann giro den stock in
asch gesteckt alter bist du meinst du
mal kaputt oder w ja ich werde der stoff
so tief stecken bis ganzen gedärme
explodieren als ob ich da gefällt bin
water fähig was ist das ehepaar
checkpoint klima check von kriegen nacke
und jetzt gehen darunter so ist ehrlich
alles easy to sehr schön gut alles
dzombic und ich schwer für unterwegs ist
so der hässlichkeit einfach weil ich
will dass sie nach vorne teleportiert
würde ich finde die runde habe ich schon
verkäufer ich habe bloß sachen gold
rüstung hatte johann vielleicht
verkappter lustig
mein name ist scheiße und ich versuche
heute mal luft hp ist scheiße alles klar
sein junge des schwer sein name ist
scheiße in der versucht hat einfach mal
lustig zu sein bin ich zufällig dj mosey
nähe oder wenn ich nicht im auge
behalten da war ich relativ weit vorne
ich bin tatsächlich dj mosey ja immer
schon vorne war ich diese chance habe
ich wenig in der optik alter du hast ein
klick in einer presse machen
das ist so schwierig da durch zu laufen
das alles mitzumachen
ja jetzt ja ich will nur diesen schwung
bekommen ja dass wir noch weiter nach
vorne wie haben wir zwei minuten vor
junge junge junge
wo bist du gerade diese kinder ja und
das ist das echt ärgerlich war richtig
richtig froh dass der einfache
durchgekommen
ja sie glück gehabt ein stück dreck
erste gasquet man sagt ja ein weiser
mann hat mal gesagt will ist wenn glück
zur gewohnheit wird ein weiser mann hat
mal gesagt texte sein finger ganz die
bilder dann ist er hässlich
ok ich würde mal sagen kann ich habe
botschaften sicher sowieso einen kleinen
grünen smaragd lokführer
hallo mein name ist peter nicht lustig
man sparen kann als ich endlich mal
einfach kurz und knackig fertig kleider
wenn ich jetzt bin ich wohne bekommen
ich werde dich töten leute schreibt man
die kommentare wie viel springen euch
auch heute verpasst hat was sage ich
sprünge wie viele kisten ich heute
verpasst hat hat mir das mal rein
sie mit mir
laut höher höher gibt ein paar youtuber
die sitzt einfach jeden abend zu hause
in singen so verzichte ich ja wieder
vier themen wir sind teams im team alles
gut geschützt die sag ich bin ich
beschütze dich schlau nicht schlagen ist
doch warte ich nicht ich glaube ich habe
meine ganzen stoff weggeworfen ja aber
ich scheiße ja wirklich nicht mitgedacht
ich hätte noch einen justin stein schwer
auf der weg lauft direkt auf der weg ist
nicht alles gut
lasst uns mal versuchen das team mit
drei leben zu machen oder es noch 2 ja
aber ich hab den typen richtig gegeben
habt also ich habe zwei kinder so
gemacht und dann kam niemand hat mich
abgeschlossen folgt mir anders weiß auch
gar nicht möglich den den einmaligen
karte töten
der schein malek einmalig einziger
einmal packen
ja genau ich mich sowieso was du lass
mich in ruhe was ich trage mantel die
jacke
die reaktion kommt postwendend im chat
ich gebe noch ja aber nicht mehr lange
weil wir manche tragen
wir zeigen jetzt dass wir zeigen wie es
ärger mit seinem fahrrad gemachte studie
geschrieben ich trage ja farid bang hat
glaube ich auf den bildern ist okay ich
hier wieder raus zu den anderen ab denen
sie dachte so noko ist einfach ganz
einmal bleibt mit 70 bleibt
kassel
ja ich auch immer ich weiß nicht warum
vielleicht haben die hier noch ein
vorteil wie youtube deftige range
zwischen player t
ihr habt zwei pedelecs aber die range
ist gut bei euch aller das ist fakt was
mordkomplott ausrüstung willst du mir
sagen wagen außer ist nachricht
vielleicht dann sag ich jetzt ggf
okay man die gwg wars oder star hatte
noch etwas cooles are change agents die
natürlich natürlich nehmen wir nehmen
jetzt haben noch einen gegner decker
dass das falsch war richtig schnell
durchboxen man richtig schnell gibt gas
gibt
er gibt gas lauf doch schnell
das tut mir leid ich wollte dich nicht
unter druck setzen
tut mir sehr sehr leid
so verleiht wie wenn die fluglinien die
ketchup transportiert auf einmal ein
wenig beinfreiheit hat leiden findet es
nicht lustig weiß was heute gremien
vergleichen sie finden das schwert das
schwert kriegen gibt
ich hoffe das gibt keine störgeräusche
ich mache einfach um auf nummer sicher
zu gehen doch mal in den fluten oder auf
nummer sicher so card jetzt ist es aber
ich habe heute scheiße rüstung sollen
wir machen
weißt du hast dir verdient dreieinhalb
66 wenn ich jetzt einfach den weg
nämlich auf 69 alles ist okay ich hab
zwar fünfeinhalb aber kopf hoch
fünfeinhalb ja du hast zweieinhalb 45 55
und ich hab die egal wie schlecht über
das los ja ich krieg noch scheiße in
gießen hier auch gleich sechs punkte
kommt weniger kann nicht geben okay sie
das was ich muss erstmal fast noch ein
bisschen was zum essen
16 und kann erst mal ein steak und kürzt
du bist alles was ich mir egal scheiß
drauf und dann drei zwei eins und allem
den kulissen war verboten weiß schon
deswegen will ich sagen egal warum muss
das schon okay die gkg deine scheiss
dreckige kacke kann ich zwar gegen weil
die strecke erkennt sie nicht ja was
soll ich machen altana die rüstung an
was ich hab ne halbe tourismus punkt
mehr als du warum sagt man komplett in
die richtung welche ich rausgenommen hat
natürlich kommt kommt dahin zurück wo er
hat gekämpft bis dahin direkt weiter
ich warte ja ok alles easy ich will ein
kind von dir king junge djs hatte mir
gut gegeben
gib mir noch einkommen gib mir doch noch
einen mit der macht doch mal sagt julia
du weißt wie leute möchte runde gefallen
hat dann hebt den angefangen so und
macht davon bild und posten die nicht
auf install noch gar keinen fall
und vielleicht klappt es eine
beschreibung ist klar genau ich habe
wieder alles vergessen wir heute sagen
wollte egal ist